As Susan said, these drugs depress the central nervous system, which is the
opposite of what stimulants do. That's why benzodiazepines are often used to
treat anxiety. Barbiturates are not used as often today to treat anxiety
because they are not as safe as benzodiazepines. People are more likely to
overdose on barbiturates than benzodiazepines. Also, if barbiturates are
consumed with alcohol, it can cause death. Barbiturates, are however, used to
treat some medical conditions, such as epilepsy, because they often help to
suppress seizure activity. Alcohol is not used today in an official medical
sense. However, it's a widely abused drug that people use to self-medicate.
That is, they may use it to help them cope with problems in their life.
However, it is important to know that alcohol is a drug. You may hear people
say alcohol and drugs, when in fact it should be alcohol and other drugs.
You'll now be able to point that out to be people when you hear such a mistake,
because you know that alcohol is a drug.